the Joe Rogan experience all right this
thing Netflix I told him I said called
mint it's called the midnight gospel the
midnight gospel with Duncan Trussell in
Pendleton ward the guy made adventure
run this crazy it comes out for 20
Netflix this has never been seen they
its exclusive for your show they gave us
permission this show this is Joey Diaz
is in this and this is a podcast I did
taking off my glasses yeah this is a
podcast I did with Damien Echols do you
know that is he was like in the group of
kids who got accused of murdering
someone in the woods there's a whole no
oh yeah there was like a whole
documentary about him on I think HBO
it's like basically he would this dude
the I had him on my podcast he wrote a
book on magic he practices magic but
Jesus told me he was on he was on death
row and they did a DNA test that
exonerated but he was like about to be
executed he's on death row studying Zen
Buddhism like Zen priest was working
with him to like basically like it you
know prepare him for his death you know
soon as he was badly beaten on death row
he was almost executed then he was
exonerated because of DNA but we did
this interview before the show obviously
and this is just a way that we figured
out to take podcasts and put him in hey
once he gets exonerated did it before we
start this does he get do they have to
pay him I don't know it's a great
question I think maybe part of it that
they may I'm not I don't want to say cuz
I've no idea I've no idea I think
they've ties on death row yeah I mean it
seems like you owe him something
well yeah I would literally innocent
yeah I was an actual innocent person
that you almost killed and the tree made
their life hell yeah I mean those are
the torture of knowing you didn't do
something but being accused of that
thing well I know man knowing it's gonna
cost your life you really didn't do it
yeah well it was play
you know how in certain Buddhist
traditions yeah like say Tibetan
Buddhism they talk about what's the word
they use empowerment yeah you know it's
like a current of energy yet it's passed
along from master to student ceremonial
magic is the exact same thing the
Knights Templar started receiving this
current whenever they were over there
that's how it makes its way back to
Europe eventually it makes its way to
the United States through the Hermetic
order of the Golden Dawn which was the
order that Crowley was a member of
before he you know went off to the OTO
you had MacGregor Mathers Dion fortune
the poet WB Yeats all of these people
were members of the Golden Dawn that's
how this current makes its way to the
u.s. one second hey Steve what the [ __ ]
you need to shine that light my [ __ ]
eyes that's how you're gonna talk to
customers I'll just take my ship full of
cats and find another junkyard for cats
ah [ __ ] my apologies look at all these
wonderful gifts and gadgets here we got
a fresh print the time slappa elected
some cans and you want that a vintage
and little that ain't cheap pal
it's gonna be five cats he's bluffing I
can get it for three watch this three
five fine Steve four and that's my last
offer
all right you taking flakes out of my
minnows mouth but fine for it is send
them over yeah yeah Wow
yeah man it was like it was the craziest
thing working on that show with
Pendleton cuz he's like a like you know
we throw the word genius around but the
guy's an actual genius it was like
really really really cool to get to do
just so I'm sorry to interrupt you but
it's so it's a combination of your
podcast and then some interstitial stuff
they like you that you is scripted it's
yeah it's like basically my character is
this guy Clancy who lives in a place
the chromatic ribbon where people use
multiverse simulators to simulate
universes so that they go inside and
harvest the technology and sell it and
so my character has a malfunctioning
used multiverse simulator that isn't
really working to produce technology and
because it's malfunctioning every single
world in it is going through some kind
of apocalypse
and so my character goes into his
simulator and interviews people and
though in the dying world so that's
basically the idea of the show so he
took podcasts dialogue it's basically
what happens with you know during the
apocalypse what's gonna happen people
are gonna do podcast people are gonna
still have conversations so these
conversations we just set them in these
surreal universes where shit's melting
down and you know we're like Clancy
meets these various people and kind of
learns from them which crazy is you
started this a long time ago and it's
coming to fruition right when the
apocalypse hits I know dude that's the
thing it's like a little on the nose I
mean yeah I mean it's like it's almost
like it's it's almost like you knew it's
almost like you had a time and then the
universe is like this is a perfect time
for duncan [ __ ] to come out let's let's
coincide it I mean look just look at how
bizarre your show is yeah strange and
then the fact that it's a hybrid of
podcast conversations and then written
stuff so strange
yeah perfect time for it yeah you know I
think it is a perfect time for it and I
hope like because some of the like every
guest we it was we chose for this they
all had this like really like amazing
thing to say like Eccles in this episode
one of the things he says you know I
asked him like do you feel like you kind
of like we're blessed that you ended up
in solitary confinement cuz that's where
he woke up nothing started meditating
that's where he started studying magic
that's where he started working on
himself because there was nothing else
to do right any in this when he says
like I feel luckier than some millennia
I was out there right now you are like
completely disconnected because that's
the coolest thing about him is you would
expect the person who'd been on death
row to be bitter he's the sweetest most
genuine wonderful person ever and it's
like whatever went on in the situation
of being on the brink of the abyss where
he's about to get murdered by the state
for something he didn't do something
about that didn't turn him into someone
who was like shell-shocked or angry but
like really turned him into like someone
very compassionate and and I guess
grateful for his life you know and that
to me like it's like he's like the
Goggins of death row I mean if you can
be not bitter after being on death row
for something you didn't do and like
getting physically assaulted you know
just wondering every day if you were
gonna die if like you can still maintain
an attitude of service or contribution
to society in some way or another
then any of us can any of us can you
know like any of us can and to me that's
like I think that's I hope some of that
stuff trickles out from the show under
the world right now especially man right
now especially
[Applause]